So what have you learned?
In Bayes Rule, there will be more than just 2
underlying causes of cancer/non cancer.
There might be 3, 4, or 5, any number.
We can apply exactly the same math,
but we have to keep track of more values.
In fact, the robot might also have more than
just 2 test outcomes.
Here was red or green, but it could be red, green, or blue.
And this means that our measurement probability will be more elaborate.
I have to give you more information,
but the math remains exactly the same.
We can now deal with very large problems
that have many possible hidden causes
of where the world might be,
and we can still apply Bayes Rule to find all of these numbers.
Let me give you one final test.